hey everyone I'm Eric clarksonian
working as computer vision researcher at
superannotate currently
and also Master student at Technical
University of Munich
and today I'll be presenting active
learning for 3D mesh semantic
segmentation
okay
so let's start first about talking uh
with talking about the data and so and
also we need to know why exactly during
this last several years uh the interest
in this 3D data is increasing
so in the right hand side we see some
examples of this 3D data there are
usually scans and of indoor scenes or
outdoor scenes so above you see a scan
of indoor scene and these things usually
are obtained with a rgbd cameras and
with this image and depth maps they
usually
can make a reconstruction and obtain a
3D mesh model and these mesh models are
composed of vertices like the point
clouds in general and also we have the
faces or so to say the triangles which
show which three vertices are connected
with each other so you can guess the
amount of triangles is pretty high
because you don't clearly see them but
you see a surface and so exactly so a
single point can be part of multiple
triangles
as you can guess but on the other side
the theme below is a lidar scene or the
outdoor scene obtained with a lidar
sensor and these scenes are usually
obtained with the lidar sensor mounted
on a car driving through some streets
and but these things differ from the
indoor scenes with the fact that they
only contain the point clouds and no
surfaces are present there
okay and
so yeah these these data you can imagine
is much more precise compared to image
data for example if used in for
autonomous driving uh scenarios or the
autonomous agents or operating in indoor
scenarios and they they are usually
preferred uh in this safety critical
applications because you can imagine
that for autonomous driving every
centimeter can matter for example if it
should avoid some obstacle or even
some collusion
and yeah so let's also talk about the
tasks so this 3D semantic segmentation
so it's pretty straightforward if you
are
if you are familiar with usual semantic
segmentation of images so the goal is to
label
each point in this point Cloud to one of
the classes that we have in this data
set
and usually
we label the points in a scene using the
position information like x y z
coordinates of the point in the scene
also using utilizing color information
of the point and also surface normal
information
yeah so the task is so we can say that
this 3D semantic segmentation task is
relatively recent and the models are
also
relatively new but
the earliest methods tackling this
problem are the point-based methods
and they usually utilize some shared
multi-layer perceptron and so each point
is processed with this and even I'll
later present the architecture of the
model and you'll see that even in all
layers of this network that share their
mail the MLP is the same and so you can
imagine that these kind of networks have
really are pretty small and also pretty
fast and that's why
they are usually preferred when we are
trying to perform some other tasks in
addition to the downstream task of
semantic segmentation which is in our
case the active learning and yeah so
there are advantages
as I said lightweight and fast but they
have also a disadvantage because you can
imagine that because we are using some
fully connected layers in the shared MLP
it can't process the whole scene at once
because we would have a tremendous
amount of fully connect of neurons in
the fully connected layer because these
kind of scenes you usually contain some
500 000 points for example or even more
and that's why they process the scenes
by dividing them in small chunks
you can imagine that we can for example
put a 3D bounding box around the scene
by finding the like the point with the
minimal uh coordinates or and also the
maximal coordinates and then chunk this
bounding box into the smaller rectangles
and process like feeding to the network
the points that all in these small
chunks
yeah and examples of these kind of
architectures are Point net Point net
plus plus and KP cone
and later Solutions uh yeah I also
forgot to mention that one disadvantage
in uh dividing the scene in small chunks
you can imagine that the network is not
aware aware of the uh
the global context of the scene because
it only seems in one like we feed only a
small chunk through the network and it
is not aware what other things are there
on the other chunks in the in the scene
and then these sparse conf based
Solutions uh came and replaced this
point by Point based Solutions and they
are using the ideas of sparse
convolutions and as you can guess these
Point clouds especially uh in the case
of uh outdoor scenarios like lidar Point
clouds are pretty sparse and
naturally these parts convolutions can
be applied to them and but they are not
Point based
point-based Solutions which means that
usually this 3D scene gets voxelized and
then they start this convolutions
operate on the the only sparse work
cells but the greatest advantage that
they are that they have is that they
process the whole scene at once and we
don't chunk it here and so they
naturally achieve a high higher uh
accuracy like mean intersection over
Union in case of the semantic
segmentation task because they are
pretty aware of the global context
and the example of these networks are
sparse combat or mix 3D is the most
recent one
okay
so let's talk about the appointment plus
plus model which I used in this Active
Learning experiment because as I said
they are pretty lightweight and pretty
easy to experiment with
because training also takes a small
amount of time compared to the as part
of based networks and yeah so basically
as I said they are lightweight fast and
uh point-based approaches and also easy
to use and you can see the architecture
below so they are composed this
appointment plus plus is composed of
site obstruction layers you can see in
the own left side which in turn is
composed of this sampling and grouping
layer followed by a point net layer this
appointment layer is the shared MLP that
I talked about on the previous slides
and
everywhere where you see this
appointment layer they use exactly the
same MLP with the same weights and
that's why it is pretty lightweight and
you can imagine this network is uh has
some kind of encoder decoder
architecture I applied on a point on
point sets because with sampling and
grouping we reduce the number of points
that gets feed fed into the point net
on the next layer and also yeah also
this like the shared MLP doesn't change
the XYZ coordinates of any points it
does it just changes the feature
Dimension so as you can guess for
example the points entering the
uh this shared MLP in the beginning are
of some dimensionality for example six
because we have the color information
RGB and Then followed also the point
normal information and it just
transforms it to
another uh brings it to another
dimensionality and
we proceed this way but yeah this
encoder decoder architecture like as I
said is uh
achieved through this sampling and
grouping operation that is performed
before feeding the appointment and on
the right side we have two options so in
our case we will proceed with the upper
part which is corresponding for the
segmentation we can also as you can
imagine perform a classification because
in 3D scenes we can also have this task
we can have a scan of a single object
and we only for example could need to
classify it but in our case we need to
segment so we need to have a label for
each point that was fed into the network
and so on the upper part is the
segmentation part which performs the up
sampling with infra interpolation and
here we utilize the unit Point net uh
which is something similar to one-on-one
columns and just is responsible for
combining the higher dimensional feature
maps that we had there
and yeah we achieve a final score like
Point per Point scores in the output
like it's the softmax course that show
the probability that point belongs to
that class
okay as I said
there are these three parts that we need
to understand in the point net
architecture which is the sampling so uh
we'll use this farthest point uh
sampling
which is followed by grouping I'll talk
more specifically explain each of them
on the next slide and then yeah it's
followed by grouping which is a simple
ball query and groups the points that
follow in that fall in a ball
around some chosen points and then we
feed it to the point net which is the
shared MLP and which
yeah which generates like uh the input
the output features from some input
features at this point cloud
okay so this farthest point sampling is
some kind of it's something similar to
KMS plus initialization and we start by
with a random point from our Point cloud
and then so imagine we need to choose
some endpoints that are maximally uh
that maximally cover our Point Cloud
which means that we start with a random
point and then take the next point which
is for this from the point we took
before
which was taken randomly and then the
third one is taken uh
the point that has the maximal distance
from both of the points taken before and
so on so why I said it's pretty similar
to kami's initialization is it's a the
same thing uh mainly but without any
random sampling component which is
present in the KMS initialization
chemist plus initialization
okay so as you can imagine we did this
sampling to get some centroid points
because we needed to lower the number of
points as I said in this set abstraction
layer to be fed onto the following point
that we shared MLP so we did this and
got the centroid points and also we do
this ball query which means that we need
to identify which points are in the
neighborhood of the centroids we have
chosen so each point you can imagine
gets assigned to a single centroid that
closest to it
and yeah we have an alternative of K
nearest neighbor grouping but this one
is much easier
to implement which which means also
which is much faster and also uh yeah
that's why we choose during this during
our experiments so that the training is
significantly faster
and then finally we need to generate
features with a point net
that uses the shared MLP as I said
so this point net utilizes both so it it
generates feature maps for both the
big amount of points that we had and
also uh separately for only centroids
which is visualized
in the picture on the right side and
later it all it contact concatenates
these features together and this is the
this is the final feature map of a point
that passes through a single set
abstraction layer in this case
okay so we
we saw the architecture in depth so to
say of the point at plus plus now let's
also talk about the active learning at
and what is it about generally so
usually we have so when we start with an
unlabeled pool uh
of a data set and we need to label so
ideally if we have unlimited budget we
can label all all of these unlabeled
pools but usually that's not the case
and maybe this unlabeled tool is too
huge and it would be ideal to select the
most informative points so to say out of
this unlabeled tool and label only those
points and only those points will be
used for training our ml or DL model and
this
cycle is the whole life cycle so to say
if an active learning method because it
starts with an unlabeled pool and in the
beginning you can imagine we we can
start with a random sample out of this
unlabeled pool and then ask a human
annotator for example to label this
points and then and we use all these
labeled points as a training set and
train machine learning model on it and
later we can use this machine learning
model to process all the unlabeled
points and see and get a score of
information so to say for each of these
unlabeled pools
each of the point in this unlabeled pool
and then see what are the most
informative points here one example of
score of information can be the
uncertainty that the model has on the
Pawns in the unlabeled pool and so the
points with highest uncertainty will be
selected like if we need to select
endpoints in every cycle we'll select
the N most
on the endpoints that where the model is
the most uncertain
and ask the annotator to annotate these
points and then we add these points to
the label pool that we have so it gets
bigger and bigger in each cycle and we
retrain the model on this bigger step
and so on WE perform this cycle for
example as long as it takes until we
reach our annotation budget for example
okay and let's talk about the specific
approach so as as you can imagine there
can be a
pretty um
so there are pretty
much different uh ways to measure the
informativeness of the points and this
Monte Carlo Dropout is one way to
achieve this and what it's what's the
idea behind it as you can see in the
below we have the same architecture of
our Point net and this Monte Carlo
Dropout method is just says that when we
have a trained model or already we can
add a Dropout layer
usually right before the final layer
when we get the soft mug softmax scores
for each point and we keep this Dropout
layer active during the inference and
for example a run inference several
times on the same input Point cloud
say on the right side I have the formula
for this imagine you you run for each
input Point Cloud 20 times this network
with the active Dropout and
because the Dropout is active and some
weights are cut off randomly during each
run we the outputs the outputs of Max
probabilities can be pretty different
and on the points that the network is
the most uncertain this out output
probabilities will be very different
which will make the
entropy score higher for these points
that's comp computed above and so uh
we'll then select
the point clouds that have the highest
entropy score
with this approach
okay and yeah so let's also talk finally
about the specific experiments that were
uh
performed and for this case for this
experiment we use the scanner data set
which is an example of indoor scene data
set that I showed on the second slide in
my presentation and as you can imagine
we can perform experiments on different
granularity levels
so to say for example scene level so we
can make this Active Learning algorithm
run and then select whole scenes out of
the pool
and this is the biggest granularity
level I would say and then
we can also select a segment from each
scene for example we can have some over
segmentation of the scene which doesn't
show the
like which doesn't have the class of a
segment but just segments it depending
on the color or normal information and
then we can run the algorithm to just
choose a segment in each cycle and then
the lowest granularity level is choosing
points like we can say that for example
in Interactive Learning Cycle we need we
need to choose hundred points for each
scene of our labeled pool
and we compare with each other three
heuristics the AMC throw power heuristic
which is our Active Learning method so
we'll need to compare it to a random
choosing so if it significantly or
performs the random choosing this means
that the active learning strategy works
because we get
significantly better results when
trained training model on scenes or
segments selected with this heuristic
and also the final one is the ground
truth heuristic so we can utilize the
annotated ground truth of the scenes and
for example select the scene if we are
working on a scene level granularity we
can select the scenes where
our model performs poorly so for example
if we select 10 scenes in each step we
select the 10 ones that have the lowest
mean intersection over Union
in these scenes with our trained model
and yeah the metric
that will compare in each cycle with
each other is the point mean
intersection over Union uh
yep so let's start with the highest
granularity level
which is the scene level so we start
with three run as 30 randomly selected
scenes
and each uh and in each Active Learning
Cycle you can imagine the ground truth
heuristic as I said selects the 30 uh
scenes that where our algorithm where
where our model performs the words and
then MC Dropout the active learning
heuristic selects uh things with highest
mean uncertainty
so we can compute uncertainty for each
point and then just compute the mean
uncertainty for the scene and then we
choose scenes randomly out of the
unlabeled pool
as you can see
starting from around 90 scenes the
active learning starts to outperform
random selection by a significant margin
and so we can say that this active
learning strategy
can be considered working because for
example in the small amount of scenes
the model maybe does wasn't able to seek
some classes for example in that since
we we could have some missing classes
that both random and
MC Dropout failed to select for example
no sofa were present in that indoor
scene
and then the next experiment is slightly
slightly different from the previous one
we start with one random segment from
each scene each of the scene in the
unlabeled pool and and then in each
Active Learning Cycle this granted
heuristic again select uh one segment
from each of the scene in the training
pool by this heuristic but we do with
the highest number of mislabeled points
in that segment and then the MC draw
power just selects the highest and takes
the sum of uncertainties in the in these
segment and
the segments with highest uncertainty
gets get chosen here and random yeah it
just selects the scenes randomly as you
can see here we also have this kind of
uh warm-up period where the performance
of active learning or and random are
close to each other and it does in this
case it even some kind of really small
margin down performs it but after uh
some we reach some number of segments it
starts to outperform on the random curve
and is getting closer and closer to the
ground to truth curve
and finally we also performed a the
point level uh experiment and in this
case we start with 100 random points
from each scene and then in each cycle
we select a hundred random points
with ground through heuristic again we
just select a hundred points from
mislabeled points and then with the MC
dropouts again with highest point
uncertainties 100 points and then
randomly this graph as you can see again
after some number of points we have or
we see the over performance of Dropout
MC drop out heuristic but it's much more
messy because the number of points that
the model uses during training is pretty
low because we have 100 points from each
scene and you can imagine there for
example 1200 scenes in total in the data
set so uh it doesn't see too much points
during the training
and then finally
um
I want to talk also a little bit about
future work
currently I would say a kind of a
present work and yeah so the problem
with this Active Learning methods as you
could guess from the presentation is the
speed
in which they operate so you can imagine
if for example the we want to implement
them in an annotation tool so we'll use
the model to select to estimate yet the
uncertainties
of points and this network
so in from each cycle for example if it
selected some points and says please
annotate these points recommend you to
annotate that point so the problem is
that after you annotate them it needs to
be retrained on these new points that
you annotated and this training process
is the biggest bottleneck here and we
try to speed up this training process
for example by so usually we retrain
from scratch the model but
we want to try some future learning or
one shot learning
methodologies here to significantly
speed up this training process that can
be some kind of implemented in The
annotation tool integrate it and then
you can imagine that besides this
bottleneck the second biggest bottleneck
is the inference when we need to
infer the uncertainties of the points
using this point net with built-in Monte
Carlo Dropout so we perform inference on
the whole scene with this network 20
times nearly to get the uncertainty
scores and
this can be uh pretty slow and in this
case we need to also speed up the point
net plus plus inference or maybe even
change to sparse convolutions and then
speed up that network uh net that
Network's performance with some neural
architecture search or filter weight
pruning or some noise distillation
approaches which will hopefully make it
real time and
be easy to be integrated in annotation
tools and they are used for in
production
and not only like be some topic of
research here
so that's all from my side here thank
you for your attention
okay now it's time for questions
thank you thank you a lot and what's
about the benchmarks
um
have uh have this problem treat the
segmentation
some benchmarks some typical data sets
something like paper with code
comparison
yeah so
I can share with you also the repository
it's pretty it's an open source
implementation as I said we perform the
experiments in this Con on the scanner
data set and we also Benchmark the
models there so this
evaluations are all done on this conlet
data set data sets validation set and we
also currently it's pretty recent run
this Active Learning methods until it
reaches its Plateau so you can imagine
we run as much Cycles as needed for
example to see how much how what percent
of the scenes need to be annotated to
reach uh close to the whole close to the
model trained on a whole data set and we
saw that nearly 40 percent so we did
this with the segment level approach we
showed that nearly 40 percent of
segments from each scene need to be
annotated to get a performance close to
the original appointment performance
trained on the whole training side of
this gun so it's something around
0.45 mean IOU the so
yeah it's a pretty early method
appointment plus plus and nowadays there
are more like sophisticated methods
achieving some something around 0.7 mean
IU
yeah sure
about previous historical models so to
say
reconstruct the features from points
input rate for which point it's x y z
may be RGB
can I expect
not only x y z and maybe mean RGB
creation of energy
number of points and clusters how we can
construct for example this kind of thing
an example of this kind of thing is this
thousand swabs segmentation I don't know
whether you're uh
familiar with it or not so it it's a
pretty early method around 2006 I think
the paper was published it constructs
not only the RGB or XYZ features for
example for these points but also
computes Point normals using the surface
information given in these Point clouds
and maybe I can refer you to this paper
it's and you can read it there
since
it's not called it's something like that
I
use
well the IU here
is computed for example we know the
ground truth class for each point in the
point cloud and we take all the points
of this class for example we have mm-hmm
yeah
and then compare the class of tampons
uh Eric thanks for the presentation
uh I have two questions first of all is
the you said that the point net plus
plus got the structure of the encoder
and decoder so I'm curious that the
first part of the encoder that keeps the
property of similarity between 3D
objects so is it good for you that is
the representations
oh yeah
I think it should keep yeah the
similarity because uh otherwise so it's
also used for classification so yeah
that's why yeah that's my reasoning so
yeah I think okay and one more question
about the complexity of the training and
the inference so you said that the every
single layer here is MLPs yeah it's very
understood so it's not that weighty I
think so how much the parameters is
tests
well then I don't remember the number
approximately yeah I'd say it's
something around three four million
parameters oh so so this very small
model so have you tried the um maybe
mixed Precision training in France no I
haven't tried it so that it wasn't on
the slide so um propose it to try yeah
yeah sure okay thank you a lot this was
unexpected to see the conversation about
the three objects here thanks
uh how do you calculate the point
uncertainties is it just the confidence
score of those points so as I said uh
the Dropout layer is added to the
trained Network already and it's kept uh
active during the inference and we run
influence several times and as you can
imagine because the Dropout is active we
get different scores different soft Max
scores or points and then we can compute
uh entropy value for example for each
point and use it as an uncertainty
measure
thank you
[Applause]